neuer partner ist die deutsche post dhl
toni reagieren ich glaube gefahren war
nur auf jene die nicht auf das leben
reagieren
ein satz der in die geschichtsbücher
einging als wer zu spät kommt den
bestraft das leben verheißung für ganz
osteuropa für die welt und trotzdem
wurde michael gorbatschow in seiner
heimat ein tragischer held
1931 wird er in diesem haus in sapporo
pohl in südrussland geboren seine eltern
sind bauern der sohn macht karriere in
der kommunistischen partei steigt zum
gebiet sekretär auf und geht nach moskau
1985 wird er als jüngstes
politbüromitglied zum generalsekretär
der kommunistischen partei bestimmt und
mit ihm wird ein frischer wind durch die
verkrustete sowjetunion der neue
parteichef redet frei und lacht sogar
und bringt der ganzen welt zwei
russische vokabeln bei lassen ost und
perestroika transparenz und umbau des
systems in atemberaubendem tempo beendet
er den kalten krieg er trifft sich mit
dem amerikanischen präsidenten reagan
schlägt vor die anzahl der atomwaffen zu
halbieren und stimmt der deutschen
wiedervereinigung zu
[Applaus]
1990 treffen sich bundeskanzler kohl und
staatschef gorbatschow zum strickjacken
gipfel im kaukasus um die details der
deutschen einigung auszuhandeln
im westen ist gorbi ein gefeierter held
zusammen mit seiner frau raissa
bezaubert er die ganze welt
innenpolitisch aber bleibt gorbatschow
glücklos er versteht nichts von ökonomie
der niedergang ist nicht aufzuhalten die
wirtschaft bricht zusammen die
sowjetunion zerfällt die russen
assoziieren fortan demokratie mit chaos
gorbatschow gilt bis heute als zerstörer
der großmacht sowjetunion
1991 putzt ein komitee von
altkommunisten gegen gorbatschow der
umsturz scheitert zwar doch gorbatschow
verliert die macht an den neuen starken
mann produziert sie in russland ist der
reformer zu einer tragischen figur
geworden
2014 zum 25 jahrestag des mauerfalls
gorbatschow zu gast in berlin er der
früher als kritiker des russischen
präsidenten putin hervorgetreten war war
ab nun um verständnis für dessen politik
im ukraine konflikt es war wohl der
versuch das eigene bild in den
russischen geschichtsbüchern zu
verbessern ein wunsch der wahrscheinlich
nicht in erfüllung gehen wird und wir
fragen nach in russland und auch in der
ukraine aus der gorbatschows frau stammt
wie die reaktion auf gorbatschows tod
ausfallen für begann in moskau wie
reagiert der kreml wie die bevölkerung
auf diese nachricht
der russische präsident hat ein
kondolenztelegramm an die familie
geschickt dass sich sehr nüchtern liest
und in der wladimir putin vor allem die
historische rolle für die weltpolitik
von gorbatschow heraushebt der kreml
sprecher presskopf wiederum der sagte
dass gorbatschow einen romantisierten
blick auf den kollektiven westen gehabt
habe und dass man mittlerweile aber eben
erkannt habe zum glück so der kreml
sprecher die blutwurst die der gegner
mit sich bringen da sieht man also dass
schon heute der tod von michael
gorbatschow dafür benutzt wird um weiter
gegen den westen mobil zu machen es ist
ja durchaus so dass in der russischen
bevölkerung gorbatschow sehr viel
kritischer gesehen wird als vor allem im
westlichen ausland die menschen hier
haben nicht vergessen die armut und das
chaos die nach seiner reformpolitik in
den 90ern folgte aber es gibt eben
durchaus auch viele die natürlich
gorbatschow mit der hoffnung auf eine
friedliche auf eine freie zukunft
verbinden und die schnittmenge dieser
menschen mit denen wiederum die das
heutige aggressive vorgehen russlands in
der ukraine verurteilen die dürfte
ziemlich groß sein und klar ist auch
dass diese kritiker von putins politik
dass die keine bühne bekommen sollen und
insofern wird es jetzt also spannend
sein zu beobachten wie der kreml weiter
mit gorbatschows tod umgeht zum beispiel
ist so heißt es dass im moment die
entscheidung noch nicht gefallen sei ob
es ein staatsbegräbnis geben soll vielen
dank erstmal bis hierhin dann schauen
wir noch mal in die ukraine hannah
hebestreit ins labor ich ja welche
reaktionen haben sie beobachtet
wir mal so hier hat man den tod michael
gorbatschows zur kenntnis genommen die
politik sein das amt ihre nachfolger im
kreml beschäftigt die leute hier gerade
doch deutlich mehr was man immer mit
michael gorbatschow verbindet ist das
ende der sowjetunion was die
voraussetzung war für die unabhängigkeit
der ukraine nicht verziehen hat man eben
seine haltung zur krim nach der annexion
durch russland hat er gesagt ja das
richtige russische politik gewesen und
hat putin verteidigt er hat auch gesagt
ich hätte das genauso gemacht das hat
die hiesige regierung nicht verziehen
und hatte ihm zu unerwünschten personen
erklärt fünf jahre lang durfte hier
nicht einreisen erst mit beginn des
krieges jetzt im frühjahr wirtschaft
dann auf distanz zu putin gegangen
vielen dank an herrn hebestreit ins
amerika und für begann in moskau